foreign
how do I improve the relationship with
my family what'd you do my boyfriend
who's now my husband physically hurt me
what did he do well
drug induced like psychosis hit me and
broke my arm
[Music]
what up what up what up this is John the
Dr John Malone's show greatest mental
health and marriage and parenting
podcast that's ever been recorded and
put on the internet ever
in like 20 years of Internet existence
which is in a long time but listen we're
coming along so glad that you're with us
if you want to be on this show
I'm gonna talk about what's going on in
your life what things have are happening
to you what things you've been a part of
that you did and you're trying to figure
out the next step give me a buzz
1-844-693-3291 it's one eight four four
six nine three three two nine one or go
to John deloney.com ask fill out the
form that's ask and we'll get it going
Hey listen I'm recording this before
the uh one of these episodes launches
okay so what I'm saying is by the time
you hear this the episode will be out
and the YouTube comments and all the
mean comments and insights and all that
will be out so I want to preface this
now because it's gonna maybe feel you'll
see after you listen to that show you'll
stay with us a dad calls an awesome guy
and he has a young kid and he's really
struggling with sleep training
sleep training was the presenting issue
but that wasn't the issue the bigger
issue was is I have a dad here who felt
incredibly
powerless like he was failing in his job
as a dad because he was trying to teach
this two-year-old what to do and how to
do it when to do it why to do it
and the kid wouldn't go to sleep just
wanted playtime just wanted to have time
with Mom and Dad and be up and around
whatever
and so I gave him some wisdom some
advice it was not great sleep training
advice and so if you had been if he had
been a client of mine basically what you
heard on the show is me condensing two
three four sessions into six or seven
minutes
had he come back to my office or given
me a call or we just went out for
another drink and some pizza and just
hung out I would have said hey
there's a whole a whole sleep training
process your kid does need some sleep
training and some regulation but the
reason I'm telling you this is sometimes
when somebody calls the show and says
hey I cheated on my husband and I don't
know what
cheating on your husband is one thing
the underlying issue is a much bigger
thing and I don't think it's wise to go
fix the roof on the foundation of a
house isn't stable and so often I will
try to make that the foundation help
somebody see the foundation how to make
that stable and then we'll deal with the
roof later and so I did tell the dad in
this particular video if I remember
correctly
I just remember getting off the off the
call and being like man internet's going
to get on me for this one I told him
just get up and play with your kid get
up and be with your kid get up and relax
and if a kid wakes up at two get up at
two go play with the kid that's not a
great long-term strategy
but what I'm trying to teach a dad hey
man
when you feel out of control if you grip
the wheel even tighter you cause more
internal angst in yourself more internal
electricity in your home in your kids
based on their genetics and their
experiences they start ping-ponging all
over the place let's try another option
something's not working
when things feel like you are powerless
loosen your grip a little bit lean in a
little bit and then yes there's some
very clear sleep training training
strategies that would have been for a
follow-up call so for all of you who are
going to point out and say I did I did
not teach good sleep training I know
that wasn't the point of call and for
those of you who say I gave bad sleep
training advice you are correct I did
not I did not give great sleep training
advice I was trying to go one layer
deeper and to give a great father who's
trying to do the best he can with his
first kid
some peace
and a global way of looking at dealing
with your kids loving and being in in
relationship and connection with your
kids and then on top of that we'll
figure out the strategies later so just
wanted to put that out there on the
internet
um and thank you so much all right let's
go to dude let's go man
yeah let's go to Jen in Perth Australia
gosh I want to say good day mate Jin's
so bad but I'm not going to because I
feel I don't know if I'm allowed to do
that anymore so good morning Jen
thank you you're allowed to do that I'm
not so that's awesome hey what time is
it where you are
oh it's 12 36 A.M
and I did get up out of bed for this oh
I feel I feel so honored I feel so
honored I don't think I would get out of
bed at 12 30 a.m for a fire so thank you
so what's up no thank you you guys have
been very patient with me and taking
this call
um it's been a bit hard to line up but
um
I might I'll just get married to my
question which is how do I let go of
things my husband did while we were
separated
um the back story there is we were
separated for 18 months it wasn't the
first separation
um when we separated I I'm from North
America and so I went back to North
America
and about three months in to the
separation I asked him if he wanted to
give it another go
and he said no
um and I was devastated but I accepted
that and I was over there and he was
here and I my son our teenage son stayed
here with him
um and I just carried on but then it
came to a realization that I needed to
come back to Australia it was in during
the pandemic and I was you know kind of
told by the universe
to get back to Australia so I did that
and you know we were always very
friendly like it was you know a mutual
separation that I thought and um
anyway I came back and it was decided
Well before I came back that you know I
would move back into the house and you
would help me get on my feet until I
found a job in my own place and all that
um but when I got back the very first
day
I I found out by my own doing
um that he was seeing somebody
and not just seeing somebody she was
living in the house
oh whoa yeah welcome home Jen welcome
home
yeah I mean he had all obviously asked
her to leave before I came back but that
has been going on he had met her four
months prior and he never told me he put
my son in a position where he had to
keep secrets from me
and why did you get separated I am
oh cool well that's a can of worms give
me two or three at the time
um was there abuse was there just not
working out was there no people cheating
on each other what was it
um
bottom line
and I never felt
I never felt cherished by this man did
you ever and he's not on the phone so I
can't talk to him so I'll just talk to
you yeah did you ever give him very
clear understanding or a road map to
what cherished would feel like for you
and here's why I say that some men
myself included absent a road map think
I'm annoying
my the greatest gift I could give my
wife would be to go make a bunch of
money and never come home
and the greatest gift I could give my
wife would be to let her go do whatever
she wants whenever she like that's how
I'll cherish her and it wasn't until
well into my marriage that my wife sat
me down or we set each other down we had
a hard conversation at a Crossroads in
our marriage and said hey this is what
it looks like this is what I need and I
was like man I was way off
and I've got to own that and my wife
owned her part like I haven't made very
clear to you I value you over your money
I'd rather you make way less money be
around here so I tell you that I'd
rather you help me with the dishes than
start lighting candles first right like
whatever the thing is
did you give him a very clear
understanding of here's how you can best
cherish me
yeah probably not we don't communicate
very well I I want to stop in this phone
call stop using the Wii
I want you to take ownership of the
things that you there you go like I
didn't communicate very well he may be
awful at communication if he was on the
phone I'd be letting him have it but
he's not here and so instead of dumping
it all into the Wii bucket and the Wii
bucket and the wee bucket like man I
didn't communicate well and so we ended
up on a break I feel like this is like a
friend's episode right like we were on a
break
um you're back in you're back in the
home
um kind of the next the next layer here
have you given him very clear
understanding of if we're gonna do this
and go all in
here's what I need I need to see your
phone I you cannot DM any woman who's
not me you can't I want to see bank
accounts have you been very clear on a
road map back or have you just stewed in
your anger
no uh no this is part of my
my problem is ever since we just kind of
I think we got caught up in a moment
okay all right
that that moment of
okay so I found out about the girl I I
ended up staying in the house for a
couple months and then
and I I had to witness him going out on
dates and and all that and it was it's a
very very complicated story
it is complicated but it's actually oh
hold on it is complicated but it's I
don't want to hide behind the complexity
it's pretty simple
uh y'all broke up y'all broke up and you
chose to stay there and by choosing to
stay there
you got he rubbed your nose in all of
his other choices
it's not super complex if you had chosen
to leave and have some self-dignity and
respect and say I'm out and I know
there's I'm making it sound easier than
it is because then you got a kid in the
mix here at least one
um it's not that complex the complexity
is you wanted him to be something he was
not going to be he wanted him to do
something you guys want to do and you
wanted to live in that house is that
fair
yes absolutely okay so it is complex
it's messy it's ugly and it's kind of
simple too
so what's your what's your next
what's your next move back together and
we said absolutely no boundaries we just
kind
of let's do this and and he said I'm not
going to change and I said fine I'm not
going to change either and that's where
it is I'll show you
yeah yeah
nothing's changed right
well very little I to be honest like it
overall
I guess the the day-to-day relationship
is pretty good but I'm I'm the one still
reliving all this stuff in my head
anytime anything little pops up like I
don't know anything annoying or he
doesn't text me when he's away you weigh
a lot and
um stuff like that then I'm like
what am I doing here like I'm always
like questioning is this where I'm
supposed to be you should be
uh you absolutely should be you have a
completely untethered existence
you have a roommate and y'all are both
decent human beings y'all aren't rude or
ugly or mean or narcissistic lunatics so
you're kind to each other and I bet if a
stranger just a stranger off the street
moved into your house y'all would treat
him the same way you treat each other
like with kindness and hey do you need
any sugar in your tea I mean y'all would
just be kind
that doesn't make for a committed
romantic relationship over the Long Haul
yeah well I brought up the other day
um about how because I I told him
recently that when we need to talk I
need to we need to sit down and have a
chat and I had written out all the
topics that we need to cover and there
was about probably eight things on this
list and I said look I know you don't
have time right now but just look at the
list of what we're going to have to
discuss and
um on the on the list was roommate the
word roommate and he's like oh what does
that mean and I said well it feels like
we're just roommates
and um because that's what it does feel
and he said oh well you know that's all
part of it isn't it well so I didn't
think marriage was part of being just
roommates it's not but you're you are
sitting in a math class holding an
algebra book
and you've never opened the book you've
never talked to the teacher and you're
getting incredibly frustrated that you
don't know algebra
and so you are expecting things of this
marriage
that simply can't be because y'all are
not addressing them head on and from the
just the short part of your story I've
got I've been able to hear
I think you understand what happens if
you set these boundaries he will open
the door and say have a great life I'm
out
I buy those things
yeah like what is keeping you from
respecting yourself like you need to be
respected
why don't you demand more from the
universe for you
really
yeah and I don't hold on he's going to
be mad at you because he lives with a
roommate who hates him
he's gonna be mad with at you because
he's got a
a he co-created a kid
with somebody who
has no backbone
he's getting you're creating a context
where he can't do anything but not like
you
and so you're getting the world you're
creating for yourself and then if you
have boundaries he's not going to hate
you he's just gonna move on
it's you maybe yeah
you don't like gin why
this is not about him this is about you
bye
oh my gosh
I I don't know
I don't know well you know like if
everyone buddy that calls into your show
they've got a history of
trauma yep
that's the healing
so you've got the immediate stuff that
you've got to figure out in this in your
marriage okay you got a kid here and I I
would I would go to the ends of the
Earth to not be separated from my
children I get that that's chaotic and
it might mean that you draw some
boundaries then all of a sudden you get
shipped out of Australia and now you've
got you can't see your kid I mean I get
there's some International complexities
to your situation I get that okay I
don't I don't have any expertise in that
area at all so I can't even direct you
there other than to say
what you're providing for your teen
right now is this is what marriage looks
like
this is how you honor and love and
respect a woman this is how a wife
honors in in respects and and
communicates with her husband
and he's your son's worth more than that
also
and equally if not more importantly I'd
have to weigh that on a scale and figure
that out
you
deserve so much more than you're
allowing yourself to have
you deserve to be cherished yes but I
mean the way you're presenting that
sounds like it's out of out of a
magazine
you deserve to have somebody asks you
what do you think and what do you need
and to wake up every day trying to help
meet your needs and you waking up every
day to try to help meet their needs and
probably in your past helping meet
people's needs got you burned or got you
taken advantage of
and so no none of this moves forward
unless you do some trauma healing
learning how to set boundaries learning
that your boundaries matter that your
voice matters that who you are matters
[Music]
there's so much more love out there than
you're allowing yourself to have
my hope is today you call a counselor
there in Australia and you start the
healing Journey back from when all this
mess started when you were young
and then you say I want to develop
boundaries because I've got a husband
who is a Serial cheater and I allow it
and I just take it and I want something
more from me for my son and my wife
and maybe that ends up being with him
probably not but maybe it does
all of this starts with your healing and
hear me say this Jen
you are worth the healing
thank you so much for the call we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from this episode's sponsor betterhelp
hey look there's a lot of things we
don't get to choose on this wild ride
called life right the neighbor's kid
learning to play Trombone weird things
trending on the tick tocks or whatever
that is we don't get to choose the
weather but when you realize how much
you do have a choice in it's so
empowering check this out you get to
decide who you want to be I get to ask
myself the question who do I want to be
you get to choose who speaks into your
life and you get to choose to pursue
meaningful relationships this is
life-changing stuff but I'll be honest
it's not easy these are new skills that
we all have to learn and therapy is a
great place to practice these new skills
and that's why I love better help better
help is Affordable online therapy that
can match you with a therapist quickly
and it lets you switch any time to make
sure it's the right fit and just like
in-person therapy it can help equip you
with the tools you need to work towards
being who you want to be because you
don't just have to let life happen to
you you can take it head on so visit
betterhelp.com deloney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash deloni
all right jack we're back let's go to
Tim in Boston Massachusetts what's up
Tim how we doing
hey how we doing Dr John Delaney thanks
for having me on the show you got it my
brother what's happening
um wanted to give you a call get your
advice recently had a life um sort of
situation occur that I don't have too
much experience with I recently lost my
brother-in-law took suicide and uh how
old was he yeah
um
uh he was 40 years old how old
40 40. what was his name
um oh if you don't want to say that's
fine that's fine yeah I'd rather not
okay you got it that's fine
um
man
is this a surprise to everybody or is he
been ill for a while
yeah I think it was sudden it was a
surprise yeah but I wanted to give you a
call because um obviously my sister
along with a lot of other people you
know currently in a moment of grief
um grieving and um this is by the way
this isn't a moment of grief
this won't be a moment of grief this
will Ricochet through the rest of
everybody's life okay yeah I agree
yeah yeah I'm so sorry thanks
um I am too and very very sad situation
and um I I just want to make sure I'm
there for my sister
um I know her and I are very close and
during this hard time
you know I don't obviously I said
previously on the call I don't have a
lot of experience with this
um and I just want to make sure you know
I'm doing my part and everything I can
to support my sister she's going through
this really hard time
um
and you know I've never been married
before I don't have kids
um and there's another you know case a
little bit a little bit more complex um
at the time of
his death they were currently going
through a divorce so she I know she's
dealing with all of those emotions as
well
um and yeah I'm just looking for you
know I've read a couple articles online
on how to deal with
um you know losing family members to
suicide and
you know certain things to say to
somebody you know when they're grieving
um or certain things you shouldn't say
you think just trying to open up my mind
and educate myself as much as I can
um you're a good brother
yeah you're a good brother man she's
she's blessed to have you
um is she live in the same Community as
you
yes okay all right
so I'm gonna kind of give you a rundown
of
um what I've told people for years
showing up in this exact situation okay
and then stop me at any point and ask
further deeper questions here
um because there's going to be call
people listening to the show and saying
yeah but what about so feel free to stop
me um I can talk too much and too fast
in these moments so stop me and say what
about this okay
um and then when we get to the end I'll
I'll leave you with a little bit of
wisdom that I've learned the hard way
um
first is basic
um body stuff
you have to eat you have to sleep you've
got to move okay
often in grief we just shut the system
down or really our system pulls us
underwater for survival and
um it's really important to have people
around you that are saying hey have you
eaten today or better yet
just send food
and so it also is caretakers that you
got to make sure you're taking care of
yourself some people when they get in
this moment like really hard workouts
feel good I'm not one of those people
um when I'm grieving I have a tendency
to sit in a 60 Minute hard blow It All
Out Workout actually
drags me down but I do need to go for
long long walks a couple of times a day
okay so whatever works for you take care
of your body even if you got to set up
some accountability someone's going to
call you and check on you okay you got
that
yeah okay she's gonna need that too
and if that's you if that is a friend of
hers I don't know who has the closest
connection to her but somebody who will
call and make sure there's food at that
house at all times
somebody who's showing up saying I'm
showing up for us to go for a walk and
there may be days you show up to go for
a walk and she's not getting out of bed
that's fine that happens but on the
whole somebody's gonna keep showing up
okay you got that one
yep okay the second one is she cannot be
responsible for your well-being
okay
I can't I can't over Express this enough
um
people who get cancer people who lose a
parent people who
um you know have somebody who passes
away suddenly
suddenly their friends and family are
calling them all the time crying can't
breathe what do I do and they find
themselves having to take care of
everybody else
see what I'm saying
yep so don't ever don't if you ever feel
like your needs are being met by her
that's a burden that I wouldn't I don't
want her to carry right now okay she
can't be your tool for recovery and so
uh here's another example you calling
every day saying Hey do you make a mow
your yard do you need me to come do this
do you need me come do this eventually
that can become a way for you to avoid
grieving by just trying to be busy by
just trying to do stuff and it puts her
in the position to have to make a bunch
of decisions don't do that just show up
and mow the yard
okay just show up and mow the yard and
show up with food make cookies and just
bring them over
um do those things without putting the
burden of should I do you want me to
what kind of what else can I I
it's so disorienting okay so that's
that's uh number two number three you my
brother have to grieve and if you've
never done that before here's a couple
of easy steps into that one um I want
you to write this dude a letter
probably a couple maybe one that tells
you how mad you are
and it might be you were mad way before
he passed away it might have been mad
the way he treated your sister that he
was getting a divorce that he cheated on
or whatever the things were okay this
feels weird because you wanna when
somebody dies we often don't want to
think or say anything negative and we
bury that part that part still is fully
alive and functional so just duct taping
over wallpapering over the bad stuff
isn't helpful during grief you gotta own
it all so write a letter tell them how
mad you are write a letter that you're
mad that he hurt your sister
even though you know he was sick you're
write him a letter and tell him how much
you miss him and you liked laughing with
him and remember that one time
write him a letter and tell him
I'm going to take care of your your with
your wife my sister
I'm gonna honor your memory right let
him know what the future is going to
look like and what you're doing for your
body is you're letting your body cycle
all this stuff through this is a
physiological experiment I mean
experience this is a spiritual
experience this is a psychological
experience okay
these things are exhausting and they're
annoying sometimes they're big tears
sometimes you just be angry sometimes
they'll just be like I have no feeling
at all and write that down I have when I
think about you I have no feeling at all
we're just getting back in touch with
our bodies okay does that make sense
yeah makes sense and um mind if I
interject absolutely interested there
um so in terms of the whole being
responsible for my well-being being
um that's one of the things I'm
currently struggling with I'm I'm her uh
younger brother so I feel like sometimes
between siblings there's there can be
that Dynamic of like oh you know always
protecting the younger one if you're if
you're the older sibling um and I feel
like that's showing up already within
the first week here
um and I have trouble like I don't want
to tell her what she should and
shouldn't be doing but for example if if
I'm upset
um and I've been through a couple
moments with her in the first week so
far where I was there when certain uh
emotional things were were happening in
live time and I I was there visiting
with her to make sure she was okay
um just you know dealing with the
everything that's going on right now not
to name specifics but um
so in other words when she sees me upset
she she's always comforting me in other
words I gotta try to I'm right now I'm
trying to not be upset around her no no
no don't take that from her let her let
her take care of you
Don't Force It
okay if you're with her and you start
weeping and she gets up to make you tea
and and
chick noodle soup whatever her her thing
is let her do that that's part of her
healing and grieving process she doesn't
need to just sit and be
um and feel like she has no utility
she's not useful in any way what you
don't want to do is show up and throw a
bunch of burdens on her
and I realize I may be talking out of
both sides of my mouth but let her
direct the healing that comes
yeah don't put the extra responsibility
on her does that make sense
and don't go over there and act like a
robot
because at some point she'll feel crazy
that her life still feels like the
bottom fell out and everyone else is
just laughing and hanging out and it's
just kind of moved on
um there's a it's disorienting and so if
you're sad tell her you're sad
if you're heartbroken till you're
heartbroken just don't give her the job
to fix it if she chooses to lean in
great and you might have to say at some
point hey stop sit down right I'm good
let me take care of you for a while that
may be a conversation y'all have
um and it and I mean you're not going to
get this right all the time and that's
fine that's fine there is the the
brother sister roles man in the the
birth order rules I mean this just
happens right that leads me though to
the next thing
um by the way these letters you write
she's gonna need to do this too
and maybe I'll read them to each other
if y'all are super close or if y'all
have got other brothers and sisters and
y'all are super close y'all get together
and y'all all write a letter to this guy
and you read it out loud
and you grieve together that's that's
that's that's that's grief that's that's
an incredible way to do it it's
cathartic and healing most of the time
not all the time but most of the time
um you're right on with the net with the
last thing I would tell you and that is
do just show up
just show up
say way way way less than you think
okay you don't need answers you don't
need Solutions you don't need cheap
nonsense stuff that people Stitch into
pillows about how God need an extra
angel or bullcrap like that
when she starts crying or Screaming or
weeping or saying it's my fault it's my
fault it's my fault or whatever
often the greatest thing you can do is
reach over and grab her hand and pull
her close to you
okay
yeah and man we want to solve these
problems with our words so bad and we
just start talking and saying the
stupidest things have you done that I'm
the worst
the worst about that
um no I haven't done that just yet but
you know there's definitely been yeah
I've been around it while it's been
happening but I haven't done anything to
like
yeah I'm a pretty quiet person in
general so good for you you've got a lot
to teach me good for you
um it may be that you play the role of
protector when somebody else starts you
know like a well-meaning mother or Aunt
is like well you know you can say hey
let's uh let's not right now
and it can be awkward and it can be
weird but play some defense for your
sister
she doesn't need to hear that Stu she
doesn't need to hear other people
running their mouths to try to make
themselves feel better at her expense
right it can be a hey not right now not
right now right now it's just hugging
time right now is just hand holding time
we have a casket to select we've got
songs to select we've got health
insurance policies to deal with and life
insurance policies to deal with in a
mortgage and car notes we've got all
this crap to deal with lawyer bills not
right now
not right now right now we're just
holding hands we're just hugging
and also showing up
again sounds like I'm talking out of
both sides of my mouth hope I'm being
clear
just show up in mow the yard
or hire somebody show up and bring a
casserole over grab a burger and grab a
second one and bring it over
and say no words and she might that
burger May sit on the counter and she
won't eat it that's fine she'll remember
my brother kept showing up and my
brother kept showing up and my brother
kept showing up
and eventually you become it's gonna
sound woo-woo and all gooey and gross
you become part of her nervous system
somebody she can rest into
her body can begin to relax finally
because she knows she's got a tribe
she's got a gang she's got people that
keep showing up
foreign
how does that sound yeah yeah sounds
good great advice appreciate it and
maybe if you can show up and just go for
a walk with her and yeah
um
just walk next to her or walk her dog
with her or hold her hand or whatever
your relationship is together
um this is a long haul and especially in
a divorce that I can imagine the guilt
will be 10x like she played some kind of
role in this and who knows what's in
some sort of letter this is just a messy
messy messy time
show up show up show up say less than
you think take care of your body
um don't use her to make yourself feel
better and you make sure you're taking
care of your grief you might see a
counselor you might have to go hang out
with your parents you have to call a
couple of your buddies
you may have to write some letters to
him who's passed away whatever it is
you're gonna have to sit in the
discomfort for a season my promise to
you is it will pass
um it won't go away you're always going
to miss this dude you're always going to
remember this time
but it won't feel like your body's on
fire for her it's going to be painful
for a long long long time and hey this
is important in about a month
when the adrenaline's worn off and
the call stop coming and the Facebook
messages stopped coming and the flowers
stopped coming
your sister's home is going to feel like
a cave it's gonna feel like a hole is
swallowing up that home
and those are the moments when all the
cheering has gone away and all the
lights have gone away and all the
communities left and gone back to their
lives and your sister's looking around a
room trying to clean up the ash that's
when little brother can show up
again
some nachos Burger
a lawnmower
no words no little special Tony Robbins
sayings or anything just showing up
hands outstretched
I'm here
I love you and I'm not going anywhere
she's lucky to have you my brother we'll
be right back
all right we're going out to K in New
Orleans Louisiana okay okay what's up
okay that was a terrible what accent was
that
hi Dr John dude I just shamed my family
what I was kind of like if Louisville
Louisville
and never mind I need to stop listen I'm
sorry k for
badgering the what's up how can I how
can I help
course an embarrassing myself what's up
what an abomination
uh my question is how do I improve the
relationship with my family when some
members are trying to make them choose
between me or them
what'd you do
well I was just fishing there but I
guess you did what'd you do I did
high school and college
I struggled uh with alcohol drug abuse
and relationship issues
um and then about five years ago my
boyfriend at the time who's now my
husband
uh physically hurt me and it was pretty
bad I ended up needing emergency surgery
um what do you do what did he do
uh well drug induced like psychosis hit
me and broke my arm
oh my gosh okay
yeah
um so my parents stepped in
I was 21 at the time and they stepped in
and they made me move home put me on
house arrest and sent me to like an
outpatient rehab
um was that a good move
um the rehab was yeah I got sober
but
then putting me like on house arrest and
treating me like a child again really
kind of
was not so good
because shortly after I started talking
to my boyfriend again and my dad lost it
and basically cut off all communication
with me and kicked me out
um
and stop speaking to me
so do you under like so I want to let me
let me I know we're just getting to the
story but let me butt in here okay
um
I
like hearing what just transpired I I
both think yeah I'd probably handle it
differently and I won thousand percent
understand
yeah
I'm sweet I'm nobody out there is taking
care of my daughter I'm going all in and
man I went too far I made too many
whatever I'm going all in and then when
I find out my daughter has
like is going back to this guy that put
her in the hospital to beat her up
that's like an unsafe drug using
um
maniac
she's going back like at some point I
can see your father saying I can't have
this
like I I've got to I've got to protect
me and my wife now now we can sit I can
armchair quarterback that and be like
you never give up on your daughter all
those things that I would say but I also
want to say man I have the little
seven-year-old girl and let me tell you
k
foreign
I'd go to the ends of the Earth
right yeah
so here we are
um
your dad says get out you do get out and
then you go right back to abusive
boyfriend
yes okay and then you'll decide you know
what I
things are already crazy
hold our beer we're gonna get married
yeah so it kind of
it was
it was crazy because I mean he got sober
and clean too and I didn't I ended up
moving in with his parents
um and really both of us kind of like
turned our lives around
okay you didn't cheat on him did you
no okay all right good I thought that's
where we were headed all right good no
no no no all right so what happened what
happened we got married a year later
okay so
it was good and I was kind of had
kind of written off my family because it
just
I mean I had spoken with my dad and he'd
be like well I just kind of had wished
that you would have just failed and
needed to come back to me
and I didn't and it kind of
you know I get his side of it I really
do but
it sounds like a crazy story but it was
just that one time thing that nobody
really understands unless they're living
in it I guess
um but now after we've been married a
couple years my dad sees us
and wants to start talking to us again
so we've been trying to build that
relationship
however I have one Aunt who won't let me
come to any family events or anything if
she or her kids are going to be there
so like this is Christmas this is
Father's day with my dad
and this is anything and it's my dad and
my stepmom really kind of take her side
in it
and I've I just don't know
what to do at this point like I've tried
I've sat with my dad if that was my
stepmom I've said
I'm sorry let me make amends my husband
and I have sat with them
and I've tried with my aunt and she just
she just won't let me
um
so there's uh I don't know where to go
oh man so
I also can I say can I say one more
thing about your dad before I move on
it would be very odd not not unheard of
but out there a little bit
if there weren't challenges in your
childhood your whole life with being
heard or listened to or connected with
is that fair
uh yeah
yeah the way when I was a kid and my dad
and I just took High to awful
relationship yes
and you've been trying to figure out how
we that can be a whole other call
um I want to honor you too okay there's
a reason your body said hey being high
is better than
what I've got to deal with at home
checking out is safer than this
this guy is safer than this
okay and so I want to honor your body
too trying to take care of you as well
in the middle of a chaotic situation
losing your mama's wild always asking
dad why are you as wild trying to be the
token of his like trying to heal his
depression and all the grief and all
that that's all you've been through a
lot right
yeah yeah
and so now I hear somebody who's gone to
hell and back several times
pretty scarred and beat up but the light
is on and you and this guy man he's
screwed up but it sounds like he has
worked his butt off to get clean and to
make his life right and to never ever
ever put his hands on you again ever
and y'all are making a lie for yourself
and there's some people that want to
hang on to the Past correct
yeah okay
here's what I want you to do I want you
to take uh which hand do you write with
right or left
am I right okay I want you to squeeze it
as tight as you possibly can and hold it
for a count of five
squeeze it super hard one
two three four
five
I'll let it go let's open it all the way
up
okay that's the feeling
if ant doesn't want to come and it's not
going to come
if par if your dad chooses when it when
it he wants to have a relationship with
you he wants to lean back in
after kicking you out
um after a pretty Rocky rotten childhood
he wants back in great but when it comes
down to it he's gonna side with his
sister
yeah
you have to let that go you can no
longer try to be the person who solves
all your dad's problems you've been
doing that your whole freaking life
right
and that means you have to make peace
with your dad would rather make sure his
sister is happy
then like the prodigal's son's father go
running out to meet his daughter
yeah and that is Gonna Hurt Like bloody
hell right
mm-hmm
yeah I'm sorry
my dream is this has a happy ending in
that he is like what am I doing this is
my only daughter I've already lost my
first wife is my daughter
and he
Sprints down the driveway down the
street and meets you before you even get
home
and right now it sounds like he's
talking to his sister Karen to make sure
she's okay with the arrangements before
right
yeah
I mean is there anything that I do
okay this isn't on you you could you can
reach out
yeah everybody felt like three times I
had a face-to-face meeting with her and
she just screams and left yeah she's she
listen she's acting like a child
not like an adult
even even and I'm not saying the ending
would be the same an adult May sit down
and say listen
I I see that y'all are have made a go of
it I see that y'all got married
I cannot take the risk with my family my
little kids that that guy doesn't show
up here high and hit somebody else and
put him in the hospital again I lived
through that I refused to live through
it again period
I might disagree with that outcome I
might totally agree with that outcome
but that would be an adult way to handle
it
just screaming and hollering yeah yeah
come on she's a seven-year-old
and when a seven-year-old starts
throwing a temper tantrum I'm not going
to give you the attention
I'm going to as Jay-Z says brush my
shoulders off I'm gonna walk out
right
the alternative is you are going to
spend another decade
running around
like a squirrel in a backyard trying to
solve all of the discomforts of the
adults in your life and that's just
simply not your job your job is to be an
honorable great wife a good partner
to be a great citizen at some point a
great mother if that's the route y'all
choose to take to continue your sobriety
and your healing to lean into those
relationships that lean back into you
you see what I'm saying
yeah and it's real common for somebody
who loses their mom whose mom dies whose
dad dies
to go to the ends of the Earth to try to
keep the family duct taped and stitched
together
yeah the hard work
yeah feels like what
it feels like I'm the only one that's
really trying to it's let go open your
hands
create the greatest Thanksgiving in
Christmas that may be something you've
never done is sit down with your husband
and do it in June
hey what do we want Christmas not to
look like what do you want to feel like
yeah we wanted to have lots of laughter
and we wanted to have silly gifts and we
want to have old movies
that might mean no families involved
that might mean a couple of friends
because our families don't laugh they're
too serious they get all uptight they
want to complain about the way you're
letting Billy grow his hair out whatever
I think the whole world K is realizing
that life is simply too short
to have it dictated and operated by
other people who will never be satisfied
and I think globally we're all realizing
I don't want you to use me as a way to
make you feel better
yeah so I appreciate you and I love you
I'm gonna treat you with dignity and
kindness and I'm heading off you have a
great week
and you're gonna have to deal with maybe
you write a letter to her that you will
never send maybe you write a letter to
your dad that you will never sin but you
process this you'll sit in it for a
minute and then you begin the
could be it's going to be hard but it
could be really fun uh a task of
deciding like what do we want our life
to look like
because we can do anything
Fair yeah it's fair it's just kind of
like I'd still
I don't know I'm I just go don't talk to
them anymore or just like talk to them
on their terms or I think you put one
day on your calendar once a month that
you reach out okay
and if they say oh you're just gonna not
talk to us anymore you are happy to just
like you would with a high school
boyfriend say uh the phone works both
ways
yeah
and maybe you quit calling you start
writing letters
and you just put on your calendar I'm
gonna write once a month
okay
and this I'm going to communicate
because this is the only way the
children and adults bodies and clothes
are able to for me to communicate with
them
otherwise our communication becomes a
way for them to lecture us and to
complain to us and to try to solve all
of our problems and to let us know what
they think of our decision that's cool
man
and I will say this
you said it's it's
um
one-time thing and you can only know it
if you were living in it
I want to challenge that
the one thing I do know is that when I'm
emotional when I'm really head over
heels for somebody or something or I'm
really raged out or I'm terrified and
scared because somebody's hurting me or
trying to hurt me
I know that my body goes directly into
fight or flight there's also fighter
fighter freeze and there's also a less
common less talked about fight flight
freeze or Fawn when I'm gonna nuzzle up
to the person that keeps hurting me
in an attempt to try to woo them and to
stop hurting me
and people who suffer from abuse often
say things like
you just don't understand and it's just
one time
and it's kind of like when the way
Holyfield beat Tyson was he kept getting
real close real real close and it feels
insane except that people can't fully
extend a punch when you're one inch away
from him that's the Fawn I'm just gonna
I'm gonna love you
and I know that when I get emotional I
have to have people in my life that I
trust that I Outsource that to I gotta
have this truck I gotta have this truck
dude don't buy a truck you idiot
okay thanks
my wife's the worst my wife dude your
wife's pretty awesome you're actually
the [__] right now
you gotta have other people in your life
speak into it and if somebody is willing
to
burn your relationship down or to save
your life when all the smoke and fog
clear sometimes it's good to Exhale and
say
I didn't like how that felt or how you
did that but thank you
this is a messy messy messy situation
okay I want you to always go back to you
and your husband saying hey what do we
want our life to look like how do we
want our life to feel what do we want
what do we want this thing to look like
in three to five years and most
importantly what of this can we control
let's set off down that road together
brush those shoulders off we'll be right
back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right as we wrap up today's show
this one's for Jenna song of the day is
from the Great
an all-powerful Taylor Swift and the
song is anti-hero and it goes like this
thing where I get older but just never
wiser midnights become at my afternoons
when my depression works the graveyard
shift all the people I've ghosted stand
there in the room I should not be left
to my own devices they cut they come
with prices and vices I end up in crisis
Tale As Old As Time and I wake up
screaming from dreaming one day I'll
watch as you're leaving because you get
tired of my scheming for the last time
it's me hi I'm the problem it's me
Kelly I can see why you picked this song
and I agree
you are just kidding
and you're you're brilliant
see you soon